person reaction has been pouring in from
our governor all the way to doctors they
say this could impact all women and have
an even bigger effect on women of color
as long as i am governor of the state of
nevada i will do everything in my power
to protect a woman's right to choose
everything we've heard from nevada
lawmakers on both sides of the political
spectrum democratic senator jackie rosen
tweeting these unprecedented and
dangerous attacks on reproductive rights
can't go unanswered it's time to codify
roe into law and from republican
candidate for senate adam laxalt if the
leaked draft reflects the supreme
court's ultimate decision it would
constitute a historic victory for the
sanctity of life i'm pretty confident
that it will it would happen
possibly in june and and this is also
showing how elections have uh
consequences uh donald trump when he was
president nominated three of the supreme
justices jesus marcus is a nevada
republican analyst and says those
responsible for the leak should be held
responsible in the history of the court
we had never had
any leak like this and we had had very
controversial decisions if the decision
was overturned our state protection
enacted in 1990 would still be applied
those who really need it those who are
already marginalized and have difficulty
accessing care so these are black women
are indigenous people of color young
people transgender and non-binary people
as well dr nica viscara says she is not
surprised after seeing how abortion
rights have been under attack for years
this would be
really terrible for overall help because
we know that abortion
is a safe
is extremely safe as an option for
pregnancy
well earlier this afternoon in a virtual
press conference attorney general aaron
ford said his office will always stand
up to protect the constitutional rights
for all nevadans